the movie is centered around a married
couple Josh and Sophia who are both
healthcare workers and have just arrived
in Colombia for a conference although at
first glance they seem like a healthy
couple they are currently on the verge
of a divorce because of differences they
have grown over the years however the
couple has yet to reveal this to their
mutual friend Marcos who they would now
be working with an oblivious Marcos
books one single room for them at the
hotel unaware that they don't feel
comfortable sharing a room together
anymore this instantly proves to be a
bad idea because they fall into another
argument as soon as they are left alone
Sophia storms out of the room and they
continue to ignore each other until the
time arrives to dine with their friend
the atmosphere remains awkward even
during the dinner and Marcus picks up on
the fact that there is something going
on between the couple Josh finally
reveals that he and Sophia have decided
to split then quickly changes the topic
to their hiking plan for tomorrow in an
attempt to ease the tense mood come next
morning Sophia decides to join the hike
in an attempt to relax but Marcos has
canceled the plane last minute and now
it is just her and Josh although she is
reluctant to spend time with him Josh is
able to take convince her to take him
along because of all the dangers that
come with hiking alone at an unknown
place they pack their bags and soon head
out after Consulting the receptionist
about their destination the receptionist
reveals a map and shows them a long and
winding path there is a clear shortcut
drawn in the map which he strongly
discourages them from taking as it is so
dangerous that even the locals tend to
avoid it Josh is confident in his hiking
skills to travel safely through the
shortcut but Sophia dissuades him
because she doesn't want to deal with
snakes that the area is popular for the
couple then gets out of the car and
begins to climb they go through the
overgrown Forest while enjoying their
time in nature when Josh suddenly spots
storm clouds headed towards their
Direction he doesn't want to get caught
up in the storm so he convinces Sophia
to end their hike and head back together
however they spot another bit of trouble
as they reach their car when they see a
man trying to break into it the couple
acts quick it hides for a while before
Josh steps out of their hiding place and
goes to confront the thief this proves
to be a mistake when the thief pulls out
his gun Josh tries to gain the upper
hand and hits the thief first seizing
this offer Josh and Sophia make a Mad
Dash into the forest as they are being
chased by bullets Sophia resents her
husband for trying to play the hero but
this is no time for another one of their
arguments the rain starts pouring down
as their pursuer is getting closer every
second right then they make a decision
to run along the path that the
receptionists had warned them about
believing that their pursuer would be
too scared to enter the area in their
haste to run away they get separated
from each other and Sophia ends up
hitting her head this makes her dizzy
and uncoordinated so she accidentally
falls into quicksand while trying to
search for Josh the quicksand is deep
and thick from the rain and it's also a
great metaphor for her relationship and
Sophia is unable to pull herself out of
it she soon starts to panic and cries
for Josh thankfully he is able to hear
the sound of her voice and comes running
to help her he stretches his hands to
pull her out but it doesn't work so he
finds a branch nearby and tries to get
Sophia to hold the other end although it
is long enough to reach her it is quite
flimsy as it quickly breaks off making
her Panic even she starts struggling
which makes her sink deeper into the
quicksand until she gets engulfed
completely Josh becomes terrified and
jumps after her not caring about his
life somehow he manages to get Sophia's
head out of the quicksand and she can
finally breathe Josh has managed to save
her life but now they are both stuck in
the deserted place with no one to help
them for now Josh tells Sophia to stay
still because the more she moves the
deeper she will sink he has some
knowledge about quicksand thanks to the
many guidebooks he has read but it is
frustrating that he cannot remember how
to get out of it while calmly trying to
analyze the situation Sophia notices an
egg lying on top of the quicksand
without sinking this gives her an idea
if she pulls up her body to lie flat
above the mud she might be able to
increase the surface area of her body
then she could possibly float above the
quicksand Josh is skeptical but she
insists on giving it a shot as she tries
to wiggle out her leg she feels
something inside the mud she grows
afraid and asks Josh to help her pull
out whatever it is it is not a log or an
animal like she had thought it was but
the dead body of a man who has the signs
of starving to death his previous
reassurance about quicksand not being
lethal is quickly proven false and now
both of them have realized the gravity
of the situation the corpse is found
carrying a backpack so the couple pull
it out and push the body back in unable
to keep staring at the face of
it they find mostly random stuff inside
the bag like a book a harmonica a broken
flashlight a knife a shotgun with two
rounds left foreshadowing and so on the
most useful thing is the backpack itself
Josh has the idea of cutting the bag
into strips with the knife and making it
into a lasso in order to grab the tree
stump behind them Sophia is not
confident in the idea but they have no
choice but to try if they want to have a
chance to escape back inside the hotel
Marcos is feeling a little uneasy I bet
his friend's absence he has heard the
voicemail that Josh left informing him
of the couple's hike but he can't help
but have a bad feeling about the whole
thing his hunch is proven correct when
he sees a Shabby man walk into the hotel
carrying Sophia's backpack it is the
thief that was chasing after the couple
Marcos walks up to the man to confront
him when he sees a large blood stain on
his chest and quickly puts the pieces
together he attacks the thief and
tackles him to the ground when he starts
to flee this causes the gun to slip out
of the thief's clothes and Marcus gross
frantic he is about to attack him once
again but the hotel employees swiftly
intervene to break up the fight and
capture the both of them at this time
inside the Forest Sophia and Josh have
managed to make a rope out of the
backpack and are trying to hook it on a
tree stump but unfortunately Josh is not
Indiana Jones and the Rope is just too
short just as they are starting to get
frustrated a ray of Hope comes shining
in the form of a helicopter it flies
right over their heads and they scream
and wave to try to get its attention but
to no avail the trees are simply too
dense for the people inside the
helicopter to spot them Josh has given
up trying to get its attention but
Sophia is still reluctant to let this
opportunity pass she desperately tries
to light a fire to Signal the helicopter
but everything around them is too wet to
catch fire in her last attempt she even
tries to light the makeshift rope on
fire but Josh firmly refuses to let her
do so if they light up the rope and the
helicopter still doesn't see them then
they would truly be stranded the Rope is
their last hope while they are arguing
the helicopter disappears from the sky
and all the fight leaves from their
bodies helplessly Sophia asks Josh if
they could cut off their jackets to make
the lasso longer but he disagrees
because it might cause them to freeze to
death even then he tries to remain
hopeful that Marcos save them but it is
a hard thing to accomplish in the face
of Sophia's pessimism suddenly Sofia
starts to feel something biting her and
she panics ants have somehow crawled up
to her shoulder and are ruthlessly
biting her leaving red rashes on her
skin hearing her scream Josh quickly
hands her a bottle of vodka and
instructs her to pour it on her shoulder
thankfully the alcohol acts as an insect
repellent and Sophia is able to free
herself from their sting after the
situation dies down she glances at the
vodka bottle that Josh had handed her
and comes to a realization if she takes
a swig of this stuff it'll work as a
repellent for the insect known as Josh
she had thought that he was sober but
Josh confesses that he had relapsed back
to drinking because of the stress of
their divorce being stuck in this
dangerous situation along with the
weight of their failed relationship
makes them very emotional they try to
contain their emotions the best they can
but Tears start to form in both of their
eyes while they are having a tearful
conversation Sophia suddenly remembers
the gun they could have used the gun to
get the helicopter's attention but it is
too late now and they are filled with
regret with nothing left to do Sophia
starts cutting the straps of the shotgun
to add length to their lasso it is a
useless attempt as just the strap will
not be able to make the Rope as long as
they need Josh says so much and then
tells her to just wait for Marcos to
come help but they are deep inside this
vast Forest so Sophia cannot put all of
her faith in Marcos alone while they're
arguing a snake comes crawling in from
behind Josh they try to stay still and
let the snake pass but it keeps coming
closer and closer Josh cannot turn back
so it is up to Sophia to pick up the gun
and shoot it but by the time she manages
to free her arm and shoot the snake it
is already too late as the animal has
bitten Josh's hand before fleeing Sophia
jumps into action and ties his arm
tightly with the Rope but Josh has
already begun to feel the pain of the
Venom and he has a maximum of about six
hours left before he loses his life the
scene skips to the inside of a jail cell
where Marcos and the thief were
currently being detained he makes a deal
with the thief to reveal what he knows
about his friends in exchange for
marcos's heirloom watch the thief
reveals that he didn't kill them but it
is unlikely that they're still alive
because the place where they had run to
is a hell of quicksands and venomous
snakes here Marcus yells at the police
officers to let him go because he has to
save his friends but the police remain
indifferent to his police back inside
the forest the poison is quickly
spreading throughout Josh's body and has
formed a blood clot on his neck Josh has
almost given up but Sophia refuses to
let her husband die so easily she takes
a knife and cuts at the clot on his neck
to prevent him from having a stroke
after she successfully completes the
crude procedure Josh faints from the
pain and Sophia faints from the stress
they regain Consciousness about an hour
later and find the Josh is feeling a
little better than before even so his
life is not out of danger yet Sophia is
determined to get her husband out of
this quicksand and get treated so she
comes up with a new plan she is going to
kill the snake and use its body as a
rope she throws random things to get the
snake's attention and it slowly slithers
towards her as the snake is approaching
her from behind she is not able to take
a clean shot at it and ends up wasting
the final bullets so she ditches the gun
and grabs the knife but she is unable to
make a move when the snake coils around
her and begins strangling her neck just
as she is fighting against the animal
Josh exerts the last of his strength and
stabs the snake to death in one swift
move Sophia wastes no time in skinning
the snake she uses its skin to attach it
to the Rope finally making it long
enough to reach the tree stop she throws
the Rope again and again until finally
it is able to wrap around the stomp she
crawls out of the quicksand as fast as
she can and quickly tries to help Josh
get out but Josh has already been
rendered immobile because of the Venom
and cannot even muster the strength to
grab her hand left with no other choice
she stumbles through the forest with her
weak body to try to find someone who
could help her husband it is almost
night time when she manages to reach the
road in her Delirious state by a
miraculous coincidence Marcos arrives in
time with an ambulance and a search team
that quickly run into the forest to
search for Josh and Sophia silently
keeps staring in their Direction hoping
to find news of her husband the movie
ends on a happy note as Josh is brought
out of the forest in a Stretcher he is
alive and conscious which is a huge
relief to Sophia as she eagerly steps
forward to give him a kiss hopefully
this ordeal would Mark the beginning of
another phase of their relationship as
they let go of old grudges and start
anew subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching